so when you look at the the landscape
now you you're obviously in the running
for a shot at the title has anybody give
you any indication of what you would
have to do to get a shot at whose bond
or to be next in line well the next one
is this uh this idiot I won't even
mention his name on your show because
I'm not gonna make him famous she's a
fucking idiot you know but fight this
guy and then go for the title after this
homie so you have to fight somebody else
yeah but it's his name rhyme with Dolby
no no is he on Edwards no no you just
made that guy famous - you made him
famous a couple weeks ago I know it Oh
[Music]
whoo men yeah oh that's right you're
supposed to fight it Ben Askren in July
and you don't like him not one bit
really uh not as what I forget that was
that fight was scheduled um what was the
problem that aspirin he's that new age
you know and he's like a fucking
four-year-old and a science teacher - I
don't know why yes he's like these new
ones do - just fucking talk like just
talk and talk and talk about everybody
should fuck up so when you see one when
somebody sees you in person you're not
that guy in like I said I'm I don't come
from this technology world I come from
like if you if you say like yo fucking
Joe you're a fucking idiot
where you gonna punch me in the face
where I better be ready for it you know
I'm just not going around disrespecting
people I get taught respect because if
not somebody's gonna make you respect
you know right but these guys nowadays
they grow up with these little things
Nicky just say whatever fuck they want
words carry weight especially my kids
can read your stupid comments you know
my kids have access to the Internet no I
just don't like I'm you know one
incident I remind you when Kobe won the
title right and Ben immediately comes
out
I'm khabees kryptonite I would smash him
or something like that for starters
you're 70 pounder you fucking moron
he's a 55-pound you're not even in the
UFC you know he's that type of guy an
attention whore look at me look at me I
I don't even like his fighting style I
like a lot of Russian style because if
that's what you did in your imposing and
winning awesome but when your sole
purpose is just to hug somebody's leg as
hard as you can and then I I don't know
what you think about the Robby fight but
he didn't win that fight in my eyes you
know several times we watched that fight
several times I thought that Robby was
asleep for a second and then Vaughn
showed it to me and then I changed my
mind
and then Herb Dean came on and talked
about I changed my mind again because
herb team was saying that what he was
concerned with his way the arm dropped
and that it was a cervical locked
essentially when you have a bulldog
choke it puts puts us some serious
leverage on your neck he's like and he's
seen guys go out from that and their
whole body goes paralyzed and saw a guy
where that happened to and he came back
is he got his movement back again but
for a while I was pretty fucking scary
so he was getting choked out you know by
getting his neck pinched it was pinching
down the nerve he was worried that that
was happening with Robbie said the ways
arm dropped he goes it wasn't normal and
he goes at it and he gave me some
serious concern Ben Askren said that he
let go of the choke a little bit when
herb came over to him cuz he thought
herb was gonna stop it because he
thought Robbie was out and he thinks
that during that time when he let go
Robbie came back to life which could
have happened I don't know it's hard for
me to say but I feel like in herb Dean
situation I think he did the right thing
because the arm dropping was fucking
weird
and yeah the arm job was a little weird
yeah but he wasn't out I never seen
nobody go to sleep doing this you know
I've seen people go to sleep
Ashley Evans no no Smith went to sleep
with the thumbs up thumbs up but what
here's what the perp said that made
sense he goes was it the thumbs up
because I want a thumbs up if someone
looks at me I want this I want this it's
not is your arm down in that position
why is it this did he do this or was his
arm down I don't know only Robbie knows
whether or not he was out he says he
wasn't so you have to also say he's in
the middle of war so I if it's up to me
I want the guy to go peace I'm with the
guys defending a choke with you know
that was the other thing that herb said
he didn't grab for the choke he said the
natural defense would be to get get his
hands on the on the hands and try to
separate them he didn't do that he said
that's herbes natural difference maybe
Robbie because he's seen this guy do it
has a fucking a thing you know maybe
Rami can't be put to sleep from there's
guys that are weird like that there's
just certain positions they could go
thirty minutes you're choking them and
then they don't go to see maybe Robbie's
that guy all I know is he wasn't
sleeping yeah well that's what Robbie
said Robbie said that he was waiting for
Ben to Tyra's arms out that's what he
said he said he felt the type to squeeze
the squeeze really tight because like
I'll just let him gas his arms out here
that was his thought look I mean michael
Chiesa said that when kevin lee got his
back and they stopped the fight before
he went out he said i let my hands go
because i was concentrating on my neck i
was just tightening up my neck and
trying to to keep my blood flowing i
think that was a little different so
very naked you know yeah it was
different that yeah you're gonna go to
see prevention ii and that one let a guy
go to sleep like that one you should let
a guy go to sleep madam yeah the other
thing happens you may just wake them
right up hey you went to sleep maybe
they pee their pants asleep no big deal
uh-huh it's certain neck cracks we just
go wool no but that one's not gonna put
you in a wheelchair no especially not
from Ben's ass man
probably so your take is on all of this
trash-talking media hype shit that you
see going on now you don't like it I
don't I don't I think I fast forward
it's not it's distasteful right now to
assembling but if you just fast forward
so the guys like me when I was 14 years
old
watching the sport now you're looking at
the dudes right now doing it you're
gonna grow up and think oh I gotta do
the same shit I just gotta fucking talk
shit lot of shit I don't really have a
gym that much just gotta have a banging
ly social network account and I'm
fucking golden you know and we see it
you know sage Northcutt for example you
know great times and stuff but um but he
was getting paid out did it make sense
so a lot of Fighters you know why was he
getting paid so much cuz the social
media is but is really bringing in those
people into the chairs and into the TV
because you have a lot of likes you know
the things that I wonder and not like to
disagree on of them but sometimes girls
have like
tremendous amount of followers you know
mm-hmm do those numbers translate to
viewers on the TV or or like butts in
seats or any of that like I would like
to know you know a lot of times when
I've asked like people in the you have
seen stuff they say no those numbers
don't translate so why do they get more
money you know I'm not talk about the
girls get more money you know something
about guys that they have like a social
media presence that are just getting
more money involved so I think it's kind
of translate a certain amount no I'm
sure it does I'm sure it does that guys
like Colby Colby's gotta translate I
mean he talks so much shit he you know
gets people excited about the fights
there's something to it I don't know I
just I appreciate what you're saying
though and I look I appreciate the way
1fc handles things because they
concentrate on just fighters being
honorable and fighting their best and
fighting the best fighters they can
fight and they don't emphasize that shit
talking at all they emphasize the
martial arts aspect of I get it mean you
don't like each other
Jon Jones and on DC I love it cuz you
feel these guys like each other you feel
it yeah kill each other you know but to
me it's okay why he's doing it when max
Holloway fought Dustin there was none of
that there was just two guys who were
the best in their weight class I mean
max is the best hundred forty-five pound
ever and Dustin Poirier is absolutely
one of the best 155 pounders alive and
they're gonna go after it and it was a
wonderful dog it was beautiful was no
barking just biting them fighting
shaking hands full respect before and
after and I get a lot of people like
they have that uh I hate you syndrome
going into a fight so they don't want to
shake hands they fuck you I don't like
you you know but when when they're
giving so much attention to that WWF
stuff and right pushing you to the
forefront that don't mean like you know
and just to think that the kids watching
it are gonna be even worse they're gonna
do it to the next power you